today's left-leaning media complex they
fancy themselves as the only truly
reliable check on the president
yeah sure congressional Democrats can
give speeches and file minority reports
on Capitol Hill and you have Bob Muller
maybe getting a little warmer but the
press believes it has a superior moral
responsibility not necessarily to report
the truth but to report a version of the
truth in a way that is skewed against
Trump and his allies hence they take a
comment by him about ms-13 members there
may be an ms-13 gang members might know
about because they don't reach a certain
threshold I cannot feel ice about it we
have people coming into the country of
trying to come in we're stopping on a
lot of them but we're taking people out
of the country you wouldn't believe how
bad these people are these aren't people
these are animals and they turn that
comment into this Trump rants on
unauthorized migrants these aren't
people these are animals blared the New
York Times in its print edition well not
to be outdone here's how the New York
Daily News played it trump hurls pure
hate at immigrants and The Huffington
Post always a bastion of objective
journalism squawked Trump refers to
immigrants as animals again now this is
an obscene and ridiculous and frankly
nefarious land that then gets picked up
by liberal politicians like Chuck
Schumer who wrote the following when all
our great-great-grandparents came to
America they weren't animals and these
people aren't either and then on TV that
quickly bounced condom nations around
the echo chamber what did the president
mean what he said some immigrants are
not
they're animals the President of the
United States saying these are not
people they are animals it is a
disgusting way to talk about human
beings there's a very slippery slope
when you start dehumanizing people this
way
it's what the Nazis did it's what slave
owners did it's not what Americans do
the tone has shifted about what it means
about you if you are an illegal
immigrant
she went to Nazis yes she went to Nazis
do any of these people even bother just
a little bit trying to look like they're
in any way impartial at any time of day
calling balls and strikes you know learn
the facts or understand what the context
of the president said was or frankly get
out of the business journalists have an
obligation to read beyond the headlines
and report the truth regardless of where
it leads
even analyst even commentators bother to
read the full comments and be fair now
speaking of being fair Jake Tapper and
CNN they did note that the president was
taken out of context earlier today and
the AP acknowledged at 10:35 a.m. today
that it had made an honest mistake
writing ap has deleted a tweet from late
Wednesday on Trump's animals comment
about immigrants because it wasn't made
clear that he was speaking after a
comment about gang members well good for
them but even after those clarifications
MSNBC could not help itself president
Trump lashing out during an immigration
roundtable at the White House and
stirring controversy over his harsh
rhetoric toward immigrants branding them
animals during the discussion with state
and local leaders on California's
so-called sanctuary laws but the White
House now says he was referring to the
criminal immigrant gang ms-13 not to all
immigrants though he didn't say so he
certainly didn't make that cleared it
would get clear he was responding to a
point about ms-13 Andrea Andrea knows
better this my friends is the anatomy of
a smear take
comment out of context isolate it blast
out the worst possible characterization
of its purpose and its meaning and then
writers so-called reporters and
politicians spit it back on panels where
the number of furrowed brows seems to
not number the number of actual brain
cells and ask for ms-13 about whom Trump
was speaking this is some of what
they've been up to lately in a horrific
crime and the outskirts of Washington DC
last year ms-13 members stabbed a man
more than 100 times they decapitated him
and tore the heart right out of his
chest or this case in Loudoun County
Virginia where a reported ms-13 gang
member beat a Muslim girl to death with
a baseball bat that was according to the
Daily News the suspect charged with
murdering a 17 year old Muslim girl
during Ramadan was accused of sexually
assaulting another woman a week before
the teen slaying in Virginia and is
reportedly an ms-13 gang member then
there is this heartbreaking account from
the parents of teenage girls killed by
ms-13 in Suffolk County New York
there's not a day a second that I don't
think about my daughter
and they just don't understand the pain
of a parent losing their child to this
gang violence and I hope they never will
our kids should be burying us when we're
ready to go not the parents burying
their kids their lives are ahead of them
that was one of the toughest interviews
I've done in the history of the show by
the way
the pain on a mother's face and as if
things couldn't get any worse the
suspects in that case were seen laughing
in court during a pre-trial hearing
unbelievable
no wonder Sarah Sanders responded this
way to the animal fracas at today's
briefing frankly I think that the term
animal doesn't go far enough and I think
that the president should continue to
use his platform and everything he can
do under the law to stop these types of
horrible horrible disgusting people good
for her but I would actually say that
we're insulting animals because they
don't behave this way or kill for fun
thank you very much but the last word on
this goes to the president who cleared
up any confusion for all those
commentators on MSNBC about his comments
today but I'm referring and you know I'm
referring to the ms-13 gangs that are
coming in so when the ms-13 comes in
when the other gang members come into
our country I referred to them as
animals and guess what I always will
this is why Trump got elected by
speaking bluntly and honestly not a lot
of concern for political correctness
frankly a lot of people who are done
with that anyway but he's talking about
the challenges facing America law and
order safety on the streets law and
order at the border he changed the
political landscape and he frustrated
liberal narratives by speaking to the
people as they speak among themselves
and if he keeps up that focus and he
keeps speaking truth to power he'll get
elected again and perhaps that's why the
left is acting like themselves
a pack of wild animals over a side
comment by Donald Trump and that's the
angle